if you were starting today right now and
you were to launch into the thought
leadership business and your goal was to
get to twenty thousand dollars a month
in Revenue what you would do for
yourself if you were getting back into
it uh and you were willing and you're
willing to take massive and Extreme
Action I go a little crazy compared to
most so great first thing if you want to
get the 20 cam month is understand what
are we selling for people that are that
have addiction issues that want to quit
and don't know how so back out twenty
thousand dollars a month for one-on-one
coaching what are we doing are we are we
having 20 people who are giving you a
thousand bucks a month are we doing 40
at 500 we're doing 10 at four thousand
like what are you what do you want to be
doing by Target is the higher level
entrepreneurs and CEO types like that's
what I want to work with that's kind of
people that I wanted to help and so my
price points you know closer to five
thousand a month you want to do five
thousand dollars a month that's what
you're gonna sell so you need four
people at a time right I mean if you're
if you say that you're going to help
them inside three months then every
three months we need to bring in four
new people the strategy changes
depending on what we're selling at what
price point who we're targeting all that
stuff if I was talking to an audience
Maybe be a different message and if I'm
talking to Jim who has a specific
question right so we want to sell five
thousand dollar coaching packages and we
need four of them to get started to so
you're 20K a month Benchmark great the
next question asked is who are the
people who can refer you
to these five thousand dollars
other people that are in the industry if
it's entrepreneurs I guess like that's
like when I put together an interview
list it's it's entrepreneurs right
because if people that listen to other
entrepreneurs that are in a position
that need help from somebody like me so
more specifically like if somebody is an
addict so entrepreneurs are your clients
which is great who are the referral
Partners to your clients so clients will
help refer other clients for sure but
that takes a while to build up for you
to build your reputation to get results
right if somebody then ultimately in a
service-based business like this if you
go in and you help somebody they get
clean they're going to tell a ton of
their friends and someone they're going
to want to go sign up with you to you
know solve their problems too but that's
not a that kind of referral based
marketing is not to the spirit of your
question of how do we get 20K a month as
fast as possible right that's not as
fast as possible because you got to go
sell their problem before they're going
to tell people about you so instead of
thinking about our customers who are the
people who can refer us to potential
customers so we're trying to Target
entrepreneurs high level entrepreneurs
slash Executives Executives too you know
they don't want to get out of their
day-to-day life they want to stay with
what they're doing their bad habits
restructure yeah
okay so where are they going these
high-level entrepreneurs Executives who
are struggling with addiction right now
and the things that they're going to
like AAA or whatever just aren't working
for them
people don't tell anybody they're hiding
it because they're they're embarrassed
because they're successful in their own
right financially they have businesses
that do well and they they don't know
how to get out of this thing and you
know it's it's easy stuff for somebody
looking down but they just can't figure
out how to get out of it and so a lot of
times they don't that's the that's the
challenging part and that's why I was
thinking going down just to
entrepreneurs and interview you know
interviewing them or getting an
interview by you know uh entrepreneurial
podcasts uh to find people that are
hiding because that's the thing is a lot
of them are hiding and again that's a
great strategy for longer term clients
so you make content you talk about
addiction you talk about the impact in
entrepreneurship you make specific uh
pieces of content to help Executives and
entrepreneurs overcome addiction and
whatever methodology that that you
believe in uh that you find works but
that's not a again extreme twenty
thousand dollars a month as soon as
possible strategy that's our build the
brand become the face for an addiction
and America long-term play
so who are they going to who who is the
first person that they do talk to who is
it that notices is it their Doctor Who
then they run some crazy blood tests and
they find it something's way off guy
reached out to for some reason marketing
guy that I from a past life I reached
out to him to help me find a guy a
copywriter and writes a sales page and
he ends up telling me a week after what
you're going back and forth because we
put up on Facebook for me that he needs
to quit drinking and can I help him and
uh it was because he went to his doctor
and his doctor said his liver was shot
so that actually is a great Insight
right there okay so it could be the the
healthcare professionals
um doctors in in home uh like anybody's
doing in-home where they get that person
to come visit them uh and they the
doctor would tell them what you know
your your liver's shot so what what's
the next step you just had a great time
unbelievable because also you know a lot
of guys I know have the IVs brought to
their office like guys I know that you
know that that high level guys that
drink a lot they're like oh yeah I got
an iv in me right now just because it's
doing all my vitamins I know they've
been drinking for freaking you know all
weekend and that's what it's actually
giving them the nutrients they need so
that the in in office in home that is
something to Target 100 that is uh but
it would also also take their clients
away you know if I think about it
potentially
um
well possibly but
if the client died
the guy is crazy guy reached out to you
said his doctor said he has to quit
drinking or he's going to die quickly
when people are coming in the house and
doing IVs it the IV business doesn't go
away if the person stops becoming
alcoholic they still need IVs it just
changes up but they're going to get
their IDs for because now they're
getting different vitamins put in or
they're doing NAD or they're doing
oxygenation of their blood or whatever
right so those are the people that you
want to get to know I mean I just came I
had the Super Bowl I'm in Arizona Super
Bowl's here I got invited to this
high-end Super Bowl party uh on the
weekend and it's all you can eat all you
can drink and it's mostly drinks like
they ran out of food in the first hour
and it's just all tequila and margaritas
and beers and just and like barely any
water and no food so you can imagine in
this in the hot Arizona you know Sun
yeah it's just and then they had a dozen
IV stations that were being filled out
for people who are getting like passing
out uh and so like okay let's hook them
up and get somebody like it so they can
go back
crazy crazy crazy
uh anyway that's not usually my scenes
I'm not used to that but that's crazy so
those guys especially the ones who go to
visit because the people who don't have
a lot of money they'll go to the
doctor's office
uh and they'll stand in line and all of
this stuff but the people who have money
don't they value their time so it's the
people that they'll come to them or
private clinics
and you know I just went and got the uh
MRT test I don't even know what the MRT
test is uh for what you're allergic to
and all that stuff
yeah like what food causes inflammation
in your body so like
uh later this week like end of the week
probably or Monday next week but
basically like spinach might cause
inflammation for you but it's great for
me that kind of stuff so you get to know
what inflammation what foods cause
inflammation right so you look at the
people who are very likely he will have
the same problems that you have later in
life so make sure he's aware of whatever
your test results are
for sure yeah we can start cutting that
stuff out right away no for sure
um but thank you thank you for the
thought appreciate it
um but those those labs where you go and
you and you get that stuff done that's
not a cheap thing to do uh
we did the MRT then we did the Zoomer
test and each one was like about a
thousand five hundred bucks
usually but then all the individual
Zoomers is a second test with all the
Zoomers that test for like wheat allergy
and uh all this other stuff that like
each one that you want to test for and
we did 13
and the classes go insane
um but that's that's like that's normal
like people are trying to figure out how
to hack their longevity and so those are
the people that you want to talk to you
don't want to talk to the average
everyday general practitioner who's seen
you know people coming in uh with an
allergy or something or they or they
fell and they scratch their knee or they
have an ear infection or like not those
people because those people who are
saying it like at the beginning of the
business ultimately Jim I know you want
to help everybody like addiction is not
just a a wealthy person problem it's a
it's a everybody problem but in order to
get to the point where you can actually
go and have the global impact you have
to be making money doing the thing that
you're doing and so you start back to
the spirit of your question I need to
make twenty thousand dollars as quickly
as possible okay so you want four people
gonna pay you five thousand dollars a
month that's somebody who's got a lot of
money like most people aren't just
dropping 5K a month on coaching right so
but for some people five thousand a
month that's nothing if you can solve
like this is their yeah this is their
biggest problem right
so those are the people that Target
right those are the people who need to
know your name and can you target
anybody in America or you've got to like
go visit them part of it is like the the
end of the program's 30 30 grand for
three months and I plan to be like as
soon as they sign up I schedule a go see
them in the first seven days like face
to face let's get this thing done okay
but your chapter well like you can hit
anybody in America and that gets added
to the price by the way too like your
flight
for three months that was included I
would pay for all my own travel out of
that
oh I see okay so you have the ten five
thousand extra to cover your your
perfect great uh
uh so yeah so uh it opens up your Market
it opens up your Market to all of
America instead of having like Chicago
is a big city lots of people who need
help and again you only you only need
four people this is not like we're
trying to get a million people into this
program there are four people in Chicago
who you can do this for but if somebody
wants to sign up from New York or
California or whatever cool you can go
there too uh so you look at all the
people who are offering these crazy
high-end tests and all the people who
are offering all the crazy high-end
Diagnostics
um and then the people who are training
and Consulting on the on the solution
what's the diet that then after I do my
MRT and get the results so what's my
diet going to be for the next three
weeks because those people don't deal
with addiction
like they can say
Okay evan uh MRT diet uh no caffeine for
the next three weeks maybe maybe I'm
like super addicted to caffeine and if I
don't have caffeine then I'm gonna go
smoke up or drink alcohol or whatever
like you can have the plan cool but if
they have an addiction problem you just
giving me a plan as a nutritionist it's
not going to help me solve my problem
we're all addicted it's the right plan
it's not just alcohol it's not just like
opioids I mean there's sugar it's
caffeine oil so the the person can give
me the advice here's your plan but I'm
not going to stick to it if I have an
addiction problem and that person
doesn't know how to handle somebody with
an addiction problem that's where they
say well let's call Jim yeah Jim's a guy
they got to come in and help contacting
these people has been this is fantastic
[Music]
so your show then because now was like
how do we build a yeah
so that's the shows like you interview
those people you interview the people
who can pass referrals to you so all of
the people doing all these high-end
Diagnostics and tests where it costs
thousands of dollars just to do one test
those are the people who you need to
know and they need to know you and the
great thing is nobody's asking them to
do interviews I was just thinking it's
fantastic
so you don't need you can you could be
you could be a brand new channel like it
doesn't matter if you haven't posted any
content yet you're starting a new
channel talking about uh Peak
Performance
and and also addiction and how that
plays a role and by the way a lot of the
most I mean not that you obviously know
this but a lot of the highest level Peak
performers are also massive addicts
um
uh celebrity I mean there's people all
over the place I mean my interview list
I have you know probably 100 people out
that I'm gonna reach out to that are
high level people I don't know if I'll
get them or not but I I
extremely aggressive when it comes to
stuff like that just like when you were
trying to get a hold of um uh Howard um
Starbucks yeah
Starbucks yeah I will get a hold of
those people I will I will interview
them it might be taking a year but I
will interview them so like oh agents
yeah yeah Sports agents like
think about sports like again like who
are we trying to Target and then who can
take you to those people so if if you're
going to be the guy for athletes
athletes I mean look it's it's in the
sports agent's best interest that their
athlete clients are not stuck in
addiction mode because they need to go
perform with the Super Bowl and they're
out getting drunk at a party right how
many athletes have careers have been
destroyed by addictions
it's like it's unbelievable it's unreal
how many guys mess their stuff up from
from drugs
and this and there's a lot that just
never never hits public news too
um so those guys right so if you want to
Target athletes we're talking to uh the
agents if you want to Target the
executives and the entrepreneurs we're
talking to the people who are doing the
high-end diagnostic MRT genetic testing
Etc and you have them on your show you
talk about Peak Performance and
addiction and ideally you go see them
I ideally you can do it in person you
could start in Chicago it's already a
big enough City a big enough market but
if some it's a some high-end specialist
who's in Miami maybe make a trip for the
interview because the point of the
interview isn't to get content the point
of the interview is to build the
relationship quick quick about that
about now spending money so when you
talk because I mean like yeah I gotta
bring a camera crew I gotta I gotta do
something for that right like what do
you recommend
sure
if you're going to start again like
um how aggressive are we going to get in
our twenty thousand dollar a month goal
if you don't want to spend anything then
you do it through Zoom everybody set up
on Zoom and you spend an hour with them
on a zoom call and you you put up the
video on your you know brand new YouTube
channel talking about performance and
addiction
as soon as you start getting one client
then the next one you go meet in person
or you pick people who are in Chicago
who you can call me in person what do
you shoot the video you shoot a video
right you might like obviously shooting
a video yeah you want to shoot a video
so if it's if it's remote you do it
through Zoom if it's in person then you
could you could hire somebody to come
and shoot with you or if you're going to
be resourceful you find somebody who's
got a production company who has an
addiction problem and you trade Services
that's genius they don't have to find
that but I will work on that oh but
that's not hard too you message
you look up Chicago
videographers and you find or you're you
have an assistant or you just hustle it
out yourself you find 200 people in the
Chicago area who do Video Production
Services right there's a lot and then
you message them and say hey I'm Jim I'm
a leading expert on addiction and I'm
starting this new show and I'm looking
at the trade services for I will help
you stop your addiction to sugar alcohol
drugs or whatever it is and I'm looking
for somebody to come and help film me as
I go interview some of the leading
experts on high performance and
addiction in the country and you send
that out 200 times are you gonna get
somebody who says help me yeah yeah
that's good if you want that crazy like
that's that's doable you message 200
people one of them's gonna say I mean
you'll probably get more than one you
get to pick how many people who own
their own video production companies
also have some kind of addiction problem
and would love to lose weight or fix
their business or fix their relationship
because of the addiction they have to
whatever
six percent of the US six percent of
course at 40
40 percent are obese so it's not
difficult The Exchange is not even close
like if you were to hire somebody to
come in and film you for the day yeah if
it's one person that could be 300 bucks
500 bucks 800 bucks like you're not
spending 5 000 bucks on one person to
come and film you for an interview and
that could even be multiple camera setup
right so for you to coach them
you're giving them monetarily a much
bigger value than they're giving back
and you're changing their life
um
so yeah that's what I would say it's an
easy hand invaluable Kevin thank you
this is fantastic I I I had so many
questions so that's how you get your
crew this is just a state on the one
thing because you're a stud and it's
awesome so thank you so much man you can
rinse and repeat for anywhere
you know like if you again you wanna if
you want to bootstrap it but then make
as much money as possible quickly
if there's somebody who's in New York
who's who you want to go meet who's the
expert on something they're doing all
the high-end diagnostics for the New
York entrepreneurs the CEOs or big time
New York agent or whatever cool you
could drive to New York and you can you
could have your cameraman sit with you
you know when you drive to New York and
spend the night in a hotel and come back
like that's a couple hundred bucks right
plus gas and a little bit of food so it
doesn't have to cost a ton of money to
make that thing happen or you just go
and run the same the same model in New
York you find 200 New York video
production companies I message them and
say I'm going to interview this one
person
can you come and film this for me and
I'll help you with your addiction and
like I'm giving you five thousand
dollars of value and here are the types
of people that I typically work with
and you'll get you'll get people who
will say yes most people just don't put
in enough of the effort right they'll
reach out to three people and never hear
back yeah so I guess it doesn't work I
did an interview series like 10 years
ago where I I needed I wanted 10 guys so
I reached out to 60 and I got 28 so it
was better than I ever expected uh so I
get it I fully get I'm not afraid to
reach out I'll reach out to 500 whatever
it takes but I think that with the
addiction side of what it like like the
offering to help them with sugar or uh
you know weight loss or or alcohol
because I mean I can't tell you how many
weddings when I go to weddings people
somebody's always coming up to me from
like high school or something they're
drinking their hand like how'd you quit
drinking what did you do like you go to
eight age like no I just quit so could
you but but if you want to go to a cool
whatever whatever works let's do it but
it's they're everywhere it's the point
of the story so that's how I got down
this path anyway
that's another great hack to find your
videographer look at who is doing
wedding videos Chicago wedding
videographers New York wedding
videographers because people who do
weddings yeah I don't hate weddings
for a course I created real estate I
hired a wedding video art like what is
the cheapest day of the week for me to
hire you because obviously you guys
don't shoot every day they were like
Tuesdays we will give you 300 for it was
four hours it was that was like 10 years
ago it was on Tuesdays I so you're 100
correct that is it was easy to find
yeah they hate their business it pays
them but they hate dealing with the
family who are crazy and want the world
and it's the same thing every day every
day every day you're actually giving us
some like something interesting to film
for their portfolio and just a creative
Challenge and again not everybody's
going to say yes but if you message 25
Chicago videographers who do wedding
stuff you'll get somebody who wants to
do your thing uh for free or in exchange
for some time with you yeah you know to
help them with their addiction problems
that's very very solid advice Evan thank
you and now you're showing up to do your
interview with a with a pro crew yeah
it's just yeah I uh
yeah I've had so much
so it's a pretty easy model right and
like we don't care how well the video
does it doesn't matter like we don't
want it to suck but you're a brand new
channel it's not gonna it's not gonna go
get a million views probably right
you'll take whatever comes in but DaVita
doesn't have to perform for you to build
a million dollar business the
relationships are what's going to
actually help you build the business so
when you're interviewing high-end sports
agent or high-end uh MRT or whatever uh
diagnostic person
you're asking about them and how they
got started and getting access to them
is pretty easy because nobody asked them
for interviews if you need to talk to
the athletes that's a problem like
LeBron is not coming on your brand new
show to talk about performance and
addiction
but an agent will because nobody cares
about the agent so getting access to
them is not hard so you have them come
on the basic questions like how did they
get started and what do they see in
athletes or CEOs or entrepreneurs and
what do they believe about Peak
Performance and then you halfway through
transition it to you to say so I deal
with a lot of high performance and
addiction in particular so I had these
programs where I coach people for five
thousand dollars a month to get out of
their addiction what do you see in your
world of performance and how connected
addiction is to it yeah you need them to
know that you are an expert in addiction
you're not just some Larry King coming
in asking questions No Doubt
so inside the interview we have to talk
about addiction and frame it that you're
an expert in addiction
yeah and then business takes care of
itself
it's a fairly simple model
to run
it requires it requires a degree of
hustle to make it happen
compared to just you sit at home and you
make thought leadership videos and post
them in a couple years you become known
for something
right
but again back to the questions that's a
better strategy always before I started
contacting people just told they were
sum up because the page is brand new uh
have it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter
doesn't matter
like thinking about nobody's
interviewing these guys
we did this in Movie Makers um Ida I
don't know if you've met Ida yet I guess
since you're new maybe not but she did
it with um
one of the women who are on uh uh um
what's what's the show uh the Canadian
version of uh Shark Tank dragons there I
did see that and so
brand new Channel Zero videos zero
subscribers reached out and said I'm
making a new channel talking about
blank which which connected to her thing
right and again nobody reaches out to
them
how big they are how whatever because
you never know if you get somebody at
the right moment what they're willing to
do I've realized that
just like that oh sure the people you're
reaching out to are not in demand from a
media perspective everybody wants to do
Partnerships with them everybody's
pitching them on their thing of course
that they want to sell nobody's asking
them for an interview you're gonna be
the only guy
and then you're the default guy that the
next time the sports agent has a athlete
with an addiction problem which is going
to be like a huge chunk of the athletes
who come through for sure
um or you know the liver is out of
control like you know what you should
talk to this guy Jim like they might
have somebody right now who they can
pass out to you that they don't know how
to deal with like the people got the
high level the testing the diagnosis
of that because that that is a great
like people aren't asking them for
interviews and that's that's the perfect
place to find by Target
you don't need content on the channel
you can every little bit of momentum
helps so maybe they go after like the
biggest agent you know having more
content and examples help but the people
you're talking to who you ideally want
like nobody's ever asked them for an
interview ever
you want to hear my story okay and it
helps promote their business and they
have content that they can use for their
social channels too
great that's powerful that's good stuff
yeah yeah easy
easy for you to say yeah but it is
well listen I guess it's simple but it's
not easy but if you want to make twenty
thousand dollars as quickly as possible
that's the model because if if you ran
one show a week those are 50 people who
could refer ideal clients to you like if
50 people knew you who could work for
ideal clients to you your whole business
is taken care of you want to go more
aggressive do more than one a week do
three a week I just go
when I when I normally tell people this
idea I pitched them the idea of a of a
weekly show
so once a week a new Show's coming up of
you interviewing somebody it's a Biz Dev
show
uh but if it were me I'd want to do one
a day
I do One A Day because then you get your
you get your clients ready
it takes you to a seven figure business
it's harder to build an eight-figure
business off of that strategy but it
takes you a seven figure business
and then that gives you the funds to do
all the other stuff to start building
the thought leadership content to work
on your courses your book all of that
other stuff for sure good uh I'm not
gonna have that rolled out by the end of
the week right all right man so it's
only Monday Jim let's start I've started
some deadlines for myself right now
that's all I'm doing here uh those
people won't be very I love it yeah
that's the model
you got anything else quick in there oh
no or does that make sense
I mean a question about about
um do you still use Evernote to keep
yourself in order because I like that's
where I I mean I'm not an organized
person like your video content for what
you're going to do and do you use
Evernote still is that something you do
oh we still use that right now
everything we have like for me my team
we have uh 50 people now on the team and
Evernote is where we keep most of our
notes and planning
um there's other tools cool it's really
like the tool that you for sure use this
the one that's going to work for years
I've never used it but you know I've
been putting I I have you know 100
videos or more that I I would have
content for a shoot that I have ideas to
shoot so the ideas are easy I just want
to start to organize it and because it's
getting out of control every time I go
to write the book or something I have a
new idea do something I want to get out
there and so uh I just want to start
organizing it before it gets further out
of control
yeah when I'm when I'm uh filming videos
for example my team does most of the
work so like the research and the prep
and the the intros and anything I need
to know and every video is its own
Evernote note uh and then when I come to
film I just have to look at
all those notes instead of me having to
like jump between a bunch of emails or
slack or Facebook messages or whatever
um especially if it's just basic stuff
I'm sure if you were at a mega complex
uh
uh organization you might need something
more custom
but even for me with 50 people
where's the most people what what
department of your business do the is it
larger concentration of people in
Eddie
oh yeah uh like content whether it's
editing research split testing uh
thumbnails like if you ask me Jim how
many people on my team I would say 15.
it doesn't feel like we have 50 people
but then when we add it all up like oh
right yeah oh the Russian channel right
right right oh the Spanish Channel Mara
is doing that oh yeah great yeah that
has a million subscribers you know all
the people who are working on my
software company and then and then all
the split testing because I don't deal
with everybody on day to day
Nina my wife
she I see she runs the Navy and I run
the Navy Seals so I go fast and hard on
new projects uh and she manages the
operations of the existing projects
so I'm really tight with my core team or
whoever I'm subbing in for whatever
project we're working on right now and
then maybe they go back to the Navy and
work on like just the continuity of that
program uh so yeah so it's mostly around
content but um I'm personally just
working on the new the new ideas
on that stuff but uh one thing at a time
well you're kind of doing it like this
is what again this is what I would do I
go in I try to see if I can figure
something out myself first and hack it
and then as soon as I figure it out
either I don't figure it out and drop
and go to something else or I figured
out and then immediately delegate it out
like as soon as you start making you get
a single client in your five thousand
dollar business
uh per month
then you hire an assistant to do all the
Outreach for you
because you you figured out the wording
in the language of how to get somebody
to come on your show
[Music]
through the Reps that you're putting in
and then you just train somebody like
here's here's now write this script and
copy and paste and now we're reaching
out to 2 000 people a month instead of
200. you just start to remove yourself
from all the stuff that you don't like
but you also kind of figure out along
the way
and financial coach and a lot of my
content has been around Financial
education yet what's helping mostly
newcomers will come into Canada but I
have recently decided to Pivot in the
one of the last activities we did in
movement makers I
My Future Self was telling me things and
so I have decided to Pivot a little bit
and focus more on the B2B side of things
so it's working with growing businesses
to start and Implement an accounting
system and then do like the training the
bookkeeping stuff and things like that
not doing the actual bookkeeping but
doing the training for them so they
could take over a lot of things by
themselves and so the question is how do
I make this a six figure business what
do I prioritize you're trying to train
entrepreneurs on how to do their own
bookkeeping yes a little bit of that so
it's pretty much so most people would
put their systems in Excel or eventually
they want to get into an accounting
system and they would be like okay I
want my CPA to take care of this and
everything but most CPAs don't even want
to take care of that booking side of
things they just want to get like the
file that's ready and do their stuff but
most of them because most of those most
entrepreneurs would not know what to do
they would you know they just hand up a
lot of things so the thing I'm trying to
serve is help those people who are then
transitioning or who are growing to
start and Implement their systems and
train them on the basic things that they
could do like most of the softwares
right now you can access them on your
phones so it's a matter of teaching them
those basic things that they could do
including sales taxes and stuff that
they could do on their own
um I could stay on to provide like
ongoing support and stuff but I'm not
actually taking on their bookkeeping to
do and the CPAs and not concerned with
doing maintaining the books they just
mean concerned with giving the tax
advice the high level stuff so it's that
little thing that I'm
that I'm gonna focus on okay I hear you
and the question was how do you turn
that into a six-figure business as soon
as possible um
let's go I love it okay so here's the
thing the the problem that you're
solving requires a lot of people
and at the beginning what I mean by that
is like the the entrepreneurs who have
money have their own bookkeepers already
right like we have a bookkeeper we have
an accountant we have a lawyer we have
all the professionals lined up the
people who don't yet have a bookkeeper
uh
at the beginning of themselves and
they're probably getting screwed on
their taxes and but it doesn't matter
that much because the dollar figures are
so low
so you're targeting the people who like
can't afford a bookkeeper yet but are
are making mistakes themselves and don't
know what to do when you're like
frustrated with the software and like
maybe feel overwhelmed by the numbers
and everything else the problem with
that is uh in terms of getting a mid six
figure business you need such scale
because those people don't have money
so the fastest way to get to Mid six
figures is solve a big problem for
people with money
because you need fewer people right so
it's not that that can't work you just
need a lot more people to be able to get
it to Mid six figures how much would you
charge for that service depends on the
level of mess that's in there so oh the
part I didn't say was also some of them
already have like really really messy
files
um so there's a fee for an accountant
but that's not what you're doing like
you're not helping actually submit the
books and everything so bookkeeping
services which is what you know you have
done for clients what is that range for
on even an annual basis like from
obviously there's a range but like what
is the what is the range
charge for bookkeeping services well the
rate that you would see going in general
in the market is somewhere in the
neighborhoods of
thirty dollars to about 60 an hour what
do you charge 75 okay 75 an hour great
uh and then what would that for an
average client look like per month or
per year
depends on the business
on average it's about two to four
thousand dollars per client per month
two to four thousand per client per
month okay so
that's if they want full service
bookkeeping services right like you're
going to take care of all the
bookkeeping for them
yes if you're getting somebody on stuff
for example it's a full-time salary or
you're keeping somebody on an ongoing
basis it's like okay ongoing retainer
which is at least maybe like
500 maybe a month
right and most people don't have
full-time bookkeepers on staff they'd
hire somebody whether it's 500 a month
or hiring you is 3 000 a month on
average right
great so but the new service that you're
thinking about doing is for somebody who
can't afford three thousand a month
because if they could afford their 3000
a month they don't want to do it
themselves they want to hire Ida to do
it right so now to make that happen we
have to be charging less than three
thousand a month
yes right
so we're trying getting them to do more
of their things that they could do so
now I think it's a matter of skill
so let's say it's a thousand a month
right and a thousand a month you could
still hire a bookkeeper for but whatever
let's say it's a thousand a month if you
want to build so if your your current
service is 3 000 a month your new
service is maybe a thousand a month of
training okay if you want to build a mid
six figure business off of a thousand
dollars a month per person
you know a lot of people to sign up for
this new thing
versus and it's it's not that it's not
doable it's just it's a lot of uh it's a
lot of work and they eventually leave
you because they hire a bookkeeper which
which may be you but the whole idea is
as they scale and grow they don't want
to be doing the bookkeeping it's good
for them to learn and have the
understanding but they don't want to be
doing the bookkeeping right every
entrepreneur it's like the first thing
that entrepreneurs want to give up is
the bookkeeping
they hate it I hate it
so to get to Mid six figure business
that's where the it's you need to scale
pretty hard
um and what I love doing it doesn't mean
it has to be your path is how do I solve
a big problem for somebody who has money
so that I can get to my goal faster so
when we brought into the movement makers
like
um Drew and Zach and like people sharing
their story the starting price is 2 000
a month and that scales to like 10 000 a
month
because they're solving a problem for
somebody who has money so then if you're
making five six thousand a month per
client to get to a mid six figure
business we just need 10 clients
and then you're there right
um you're gonna need
a lot more so
not to discourage you or that that it's
not a fit it's just do you want that
business model of
you you're training people you're
solving a problem but it's a lower level
problem and they're eventually going to
leave you
because their business grow I don't know
how long they stay with you a year six
months before like they've learned it or
they've scaled so that they can just
hire somebody
okay so what do you think would then be
a better direction to go with this
what is a problem that people with money
have
and how can you solve it I know quite a
good number of people with money who
have messy accounting systems because
they have terrible bookkeepers and their
CPAs find it extremely hard to work with
them what would be great is and the
mission is so much bigger than working
with 10 clients or 20 clients right but
when you're making mid six figures that
allows you a lot more freedom to then
make content at scale even if you never
get paid for it
right because I know your heart your
passion is to help especially the
newcomers coming who like how would a
thousand dollars a month is insane like
there's no way they could afford that so
the content becomes free that can help
everybody all of the newcomers but you
need you need money to pay for all of
that right so if you're making mid six
figures in your business then you can do
whatever you want on the content side of
things
um so if the problem is most bookkeepers
suck I don't know if you want to smoke
say that but whatever
I've met quite a few quite a few yeah
then then it could be having like what
makes a great bookkeeper in having it be
uh
Ida approved like who are the Ida
approved bookkeepers you take you could
do the same thing that I'm doing with
Jeremy and and Drew and Zach and they
are effectively YouTube Consultants
right they're gonna come in and help you
grow your YouTube channel
and there's a lot of crappy YouTube
Consultants there's a lot of people who
say they can help and they suck right
everybody's a YouTube consultant great
so same thing everybody can be a
bookkeeper great but it doesn't mean
you're actually any good and a lot of
entrepreneurs may not know the
difference between a good one and a bad
one right so
if you love somebody
um the the model would be you take a
piece of their business and mentor and
train the bookkeepers
so you take some bookkeepers you train
them up on how to become a good
bookkeeper that falls under the Ida
brand that why does somebody sign up
with uh Zach who's who's a new YouTube
consultant well because it's from my
brand
right and then you take a commission off
of the entire business so you take a 25
royalty fee off of the entire Revenue in
the business
and then you meet them once a week like
this is what I do with Drew and
everybody else we meet once a week on a
Monday and talk about their business
where are you struggling how can I help
how are our clients what are our goals
what are the three things that you know
you need some feedback on and I'm
helping them build and grow their
business
there's messaging in between and stuff
but it's it's basically 25 minutes every
week on a Monday
and that could be pretty high leverage
for you and that if you find
two three four five people that you love
as humans and you're gonna train them on
how to be a better bookkeeper and then
you're doing venturing calls with them
and introducing them to potential
clients where then when you're meeting
all these entrepreneurs even better
meeting the CPAs the CPAs take working
with crappy bookkeepers
it just makes their life impossible
because they can only do so much it's
like if your books are a disaster what's
the CPA going to do and the good ones go
in and try to teach and try to help or
try to understand it's like man if you
just hired a good bookkeeper this would
all be so much easier for everybody
that's the point I was trying to to then
be the person but the thing that was to
flip it and not be the person but be the
person training this whole group of
bookkeepers to take care of that problem
right right but you so you can either do
like the mass the mass way would be to
have the Ida training that is a course
or that is group coaching or whatever
and bookkeepers join for whatever 500 a
month and you're training them and
coaching them or you have your course
that's five thousand dollars or whatever
and training them and coaching them
um and you can read all aspects of
business too like how do you get clients
and how do you grow and how do you
maintain relationships and as well as
the CPA side of like here's what CPAs
are looking for you here's how to this
is like the the skills of the book The
keeping the books and then the skills of
growing a business
but again if you're if you have a if
you're selling that five thousand dollar
course which is fairly expensive if you
want to make mid six figures a year you
got to sell a lot of courses
verse says and that's still possible but
maybe like if you said I want to get
this myth six figures as soon as
possible I wouldn't go that path because
it takes so long to build that up versus
if you take five people
train them work with them get them a
call every Monday and you're taking 25
percent of the revenue that comes in on
that business in exchange for mentoring
them teaching them making introductions
for them then if they're all building
like if if you're taking 25 of Revenue
and you get four bookkeepers and help
them build their mid six figure business
then you have a mid-security business
not being there
and it's working with four people now
you have to love them right like I love
working with you if I if I saw on Monday
and I saw Drew on there like oh my God I
gotta talk to Drew again this guy I hate
right that it wouldn't work so you have
to really pick the people who you
partner with I don't maybe you already
know some people have in mind who you
think might be a good fit to work with
but that's the fastest path it's like
people who are making money and we're
solving a big problem for them you you
actually can't solve a huge problem
people's books are a mess even people
even entrepreneurs who are making
millions of dollars of books are a
disaster and the CPA basically saves
them every year and they're like
massively stressed out around tax time
it's like can you just please hire a
good bookkeeper yeah and the
entrepreneur doesn't want to do the work
to think like the first question is
going to be okay who do you recommend
who should I hire and the CP is like I
don't know
right so that's where it's like higher
Ida but Ida is so busy United doesn't
want more clients I just kind of get out
of the business so instead of higher Ida
it's like higher Ida's person and if you
went to all the CPAs that you've worked
with and said hey I'm I'm starting a
bookkeeping Network and I'm personally
training people how to be great
bookkeepers
if you have any extra business let me
know and I'll pass it to my team because
I work with them I'm on a call every
week with them and and it flows through
me it's under my brand then um people be
much likely to like you might have all
the businesses you need just from that
makes sense that doesn't take you to
like a mid-seven figure business but it
takes you to a mid six figure business
which then frees up a lot of your time
and energy and finances and freedom to
then go make content make your courses
make a group thing train entrepreneurs
at a you know 500 a month or something
um to do all the bigger things that
you've got because you're you have money
coming in
okay
makes sense
what makes a lot of sense what's hard
like if you said if you had
um like how many how much time do you
put into your like you actually doing
bookkeeping one day a week okay if you
went to CPAs all your contacts and said
hey I'm five days a week now how how
quickly could you fill up those five
days
pretty quick
perfect okay that's that's the harder
problem so like the marketing is not the
problem you don't have to go take out
ads you don't have to go on podcasts you
don't have to go on radio stations or
something you can already fill up your
calendar with business if you wanted to
yes so now if you went to those same
people and said I'm not doing it but I'm
I've trained people on how to do it and
I mentor and guide them you could fill
up their rosters pretty quick
yes the challenge would be to find those
people yes so that's the next shot that
becomes your most important challenge
you need four people who you're gonna
help to build up to help them create a
mid-six figure business so that you can
have your mid-section to your business
off of taking 20 25 Revenue
so now it's thinking who Do You Love
who's who's okay but has a lot of
potential who is coachable who when you
talk to
you feel you know good about
it's energizing they still need training
they still need work
and then that becomes your new Monday or
your new Tuesday or whatever not even
it's only four people like the model
that I run is for we have we've got how
many people five how many people are
doing
right okay I love it too though but but
if you needed four people if you wanted
a mid six figure business and you need
to help four people get to Mid six
figure business and then you've got your
mid-secure business so in that model you
could have
25 I do 25 minute meetings this is
basically two hours a week to mentoring
people on calls plus like DMS and emails
and like whatever
problems they might have but uh it's two
hours a week to do those four people so
now you gotta go find those four people
and you could scale it harder you could
do eight if you wanted to and then
that's four hours a week so Biz Dev in
this one then is
walk me through the business for this
one then
foreign
you have enough clients coming in right
like if you were mentoring eight people
and then you couldn't fill up their
business enough then it becomes the biz
Dev show to get clients
but when I asked you if you're a one day
a week and you're gonna go to five and
you said you could fill that up pretty
quickly then you don't need you don't
this Dev is not your problem you have
enough Biz coming in right
and the way that that worked I mean you
know this but for everybody watching on
the replay uh it's very much a referral
business that if that if those CPAs end
up loving you and they love the people
that you're working with then they start
just sending more business
because you're making the CPA's life
easier and
the entrepreneur who's hiring a CPA will
listen to their CPA like we got our
bookkeeper from our accountant
it's like you need you need a bookkeeper
okay
who we use this person great yeah that's
how we make it works that's how it works
and then the bookkeeper would have to
like massively screw up to not get the
deal right
so the the biz Dev would become getting
to know more accountants but that's not
your immediate problem your problem is I
need to get I need to get the Junior
bookkeepers and like train them up to
get better yes
because if I went to an accounting firm
right like there's a lot of them if I
just go to them they would they're
willing to just let it go
yeah they have a lot that they want to
let go so that's the immediate homework
is how do I find four people who I could
train and that becomes a deal it's like
it's a pretty high margin business and
so we want to focus on we're not doing
10 an hour bookkeeping we're doing 75
hour booking or 100 an hour bookkeeping
like we're we're charging more first
being affiliated with I with Ida means
you charge more same thing with like
YouTube Consulting right
it's not a it's not a 200 a month thing
like you're starting at two thousand
dollars a month
I want my the minimum is 500 an hour for
for what we do if if any any of your
programs or packages or whatever that
I'll I'll tell you and everybody if it's
under 500 an hour then it's not enough
margin
500 an hour minimum right
um
so whatever if you're at a hundred
dollars an hour or 75 hours an hour you
help them get to 100 an hour even 75 is
high now if you take them to 100 they're
still making great money at this at they
get the 75 and you get the 25 for
training them and being part of the
brand and bringing in business
perfect so how do you find the four
people to train
anybody you know work
I've been looking for them
oh my goodness is there like a do you
have to be licensed
no you could be but you don't have to be
you just have to be good okay
one like
nobody checks or cares because it's it's
your name on the line
no it's not a regulated profession as in
so so calling yourself a CPA or calling
yourself a certified bookkeeper that is
like a a professional thing but you
don't need any of those to do the work
right but you need to be to be a a CPA
certified yes or a lawyer or whatever
exactly so yeah yeah so that's great so
that becomes like how quickly if
somebody was passionate and eager to
learn how quickly could you take them to
to to do the things that they need to
know how to do I don't know
yeah no it's fast because like even when
I'm training clients I train people for
like a two to four hour period and they
know enough to kind of
go they wouldn't know how to solve
problems so whenever problems come up
they still need to call me but in terms
of like being able to just take it and
start putting in the stuff the correct
way a couple of hours so maybe two to
four hours in one day so let's say to
train a good bookkeeper to know the
things that to do the things right
within a week it should be it should you
should be able to to get up and go
from what what's their starting point
knowing nothing of a bookkeeping knowing
nothing about bookkeeping to
implementing the methods I teach you yes
a week ah then you just need somebody
who would hustle and like wants to learn
yes
I mean I did this for Jeremy Jeremy was
my first test in this whole thing and he
he was a grocery store worker earning
minimum minimum wage like stocking
shelves at a local grocery store and I
said I'm going to teach you YouTube and
I made him do some research first I go I
was on tour so I go watch these videos
so that you have a basic understanding
and then I started teaching him and then
he started doing free client calls
um yeah now like he's he if he wanted to
good at seven figures this year he's
kind of not lazy but he doesn't he
doesn't want to hit it's fine
right and that's in like three years
when did we start with Jeremy 2019 yeah
um
yeah and so if you have people who who
you can just ambitious people and new
customers are great for that too because
like they're looking for something
they're they're willing to hustle so
somebody who you just love working with
and say hey do you want to build a
mid-six figure bookkeeping business
together and I'll show you what you need
to do and if it takes a week to get them
trained
maybe not a hundred percent but you're
still there to answer questions and
solve problems and whatever
um then the amount of work that you do
per person will start to is that is the
onboarding and then it falls out pretty
quickly until most of the problems 98 of
the problems will be solved because they
know how to do it yeah and that final
two percent is that's why they're still
talking to you every Monday
to get guidance
um yeah if you could change somebody in
a week you just need some hard-working
people who are willing to learn yeah
that's that's the key word right people
who are willing to hustle because I know
my work ethic I know when I set my mind
to do something I'll do it so if it's a
person who is like okay either I'm I'm
in I want to learn it I want to do this
a week is all you need with me and you
can
yep
so and you want somebody local like you
want somebody in Montreal it doesn't
have to be local ideally well no it
doesn't have to be local I train people
I train people on zoom and teams and
stuff like that it doesn't have to be
local somebody in Canada or like
because come to think about it this
thing the things which are very specific
to Canada the sales taxes every single
province has a different rule regarding
sales tax and so just things like that
if you're in Canada at least you get to
understand things a little bit better
well not necessarily I think that's a
bias but it's just easier to train
somebody who's local in Canada versus
somebody who's not here but it's not
impossible I guess
to train from anywhere
I mean I love the Immigrant mindset and
mentality I mean people like people want
to work and they want an opportunity and
they're probably not getting it doing
something else like most people when
they first come to Canada unless they've
already got a job lined up they're doing
pretty crappy jobs and here you are
giving them a knowledge worker job plus
plus you're awesome at welcoming
newcomers in you know uh you'll be a
good kind of Mentor so if you wanted
local Montreal you could like where are
the people coming into from Montreal I
mean to Montreal from around the world
that you want to go and train if you're
Canada then there's tons of people
coming into
like the Toronto immigration scene is
huge they need to help
um we've done a lot of work with Kiva I
think you know Kiva uh it's like micro
loan programs and my sister helped me
start it and most of the loans that we
do go to various countries uh in Africa
and it's always the women that they give
the loans to maybe not always now but
like how it started it's like the women
were the ones who were like gave the
loans to because they uh were more
likely to pay it back more likely to do
the work uh I'm more likely to like hold
each other accountable as well too so I
think there's definitely something great
in your story and like you being an
immigrant to Canada finding other people
who have a similar story and then saying
hey like I want to let me teach you
beyond just the stuff that you're
already teaching around credit scores
and paying your credit card off on time
and which debt to pay off first and all
that generic Financial advice which is
still like insanely badly needed because
people are making really terrible
Financial choices to find a couple of
those people even local
like just hanging out where all the new
immigrants are hanging out where do they
come like when they first land here
where are they going
um with other family members or friends
they're going to host uh host families
let's say but are there
um
government resources or
newcomer events or well thinking about
Meister when I got you I didn't get to
use any of those government things so I
I leave to the host family and
events there are some not many people
attend those anyway but yes there are
some like
settlement organizations that would host
lots of activities when people just come
over so they could get orientation as to
okay this is what you do these are the
kind of things and stuff like that yeah
so how did you find your host family
um a friend my sister's friend
was here in Montreal
okay so like it's those networks plus
how can you get to know all the host
families in Montreal oh that's like keep
figuring out trying to know everybody
who lives in Montreal you can't again
like you don't need everybody okay you
need four people or you need to start
with one person
right because you could get one person
and you build them to a four hundred
thousand dollar a year business you have
a hundred thousand dollar your business
I just got an idea okay okay this makes
sense so yeah yeah no that makes a lot
of sense okay wait listen
um I'm listening I'm here okay
most of the immigrants were coming over
on the like the skilled worker program
like I did they already have the
binoculars or Masters and they have like
work experience in their various
countries there are a lot of accountants
from home from out of Canada who are not
able to get hired here because they know
nothing about it those would probably be
the easiest people to train in the
bookkeeping because they already have a
background knowledge in accounting and I
was just about taking that and making it
Canadian so it's about where do I find
those people those could probably be the
first group of people I bring and I said
okay those are the people I'm gonna
train to take on this gay it be in the
network yeah like are they using
immigrant lawyers like how are they
getting through and
those are the people that you want to
connect with okay
it's still more the mindset because if
even if they have the knowledge they
know how to use a general ledger you
know like that kind of stuff
um how much are they open to learning
from you
because it's true a lot of people come
my my acupuncturist with a surgeon back
in China but
came here and like didn't want to go
through all of the
training and everything to become a
doctor so he just became an
acupuncturist because it's not not it's
less regulated or not regulated
um
so yeah finding those people again you
don't you could build this into
something bigger if you really liked it
right you could take on 20 people that
you mentored then maybe you need a Biz
Dev show to get more accountants on to
get more business into what you're doing
um
but it's really just finding your first
four people okay
I still want to see you make content but
like this is not a Content play right
like but what it does is you know again
once you're making two three four five
hundred thousand dollars a year it just
frees up so much more to do all the
content and all the ideas and all the
courses and all the masks because the
idea that you started with is is a great
idea it's just at scale you need you
need scale you need Mass to make it
happen or the stuff you're posting on
Tick Tock and everything else is great
it's it's designed for a mass audience
so you're making very little the models
make very little off of a lot of people
which is a great model but it takes so
long to build up where most even you
look at Tesla they started with the
Roadster the expensive car and then they
went to now now they're going Mass but
every car becomes a little bit cheaper
um and so same thing the fastest way to
get to a six-figure business mid six
figure business
right is uh sell the people who have
money and you're solving a big problem
because entrepreneurs with multi-million
dollar companies still have crappy bucks
and is a nightmare for the CPAs to work
with so like solve that problem and it
gives you the money to solve all the
other problems too perfect
let's go Ida I got my orders all right
you got your marching orders uh
yeah it it and it's fun you know it's
fun and it's it's fun to see taking
somebody
who nobody else is betting on and they
have a mid six figure business because
they met you yeah
yeah
wow you know what Evan in 2018 I think
I I wrote something down this I wrote
bookkeepers and training that was a
Facebook group I created like four or
five years ago and I shut it down I
never did anything with it but this is
pretty much it get people train them in
bookkeeping and then they do the work
and I'm the one training them because I
know I'm very good at that it's
something I've done a lot but I never
like thought about building this model
around it and you've got heart and
you've got patience and I think you'll
be great at it the difference is we're
not selling we're not selling the
training we're investing in their
business
because bookkeepers in training could be
its own business where you're giving
them a five thousand dollar course or
something which is still another that
could be phase two or phase three
but phase one is I'm going to invest in
your business and I'm gonna take four
people and Mentor you and show you how
to do this and let's make money together
so right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there
that's it because a lot of people hear
that message today but I don't wanna I
don't want to dream so small no I'm not
asking a dream small like dream big
dream bigger we're just building the
plan to actually get there